I think that when I wrote female
masculinity which was at the very
beginning of my career I felt that I was
writing about something that will was
very specifically about me important to
me and part of a community in which I
was immersed and I wasn't sure how that
would play out academically but I did
know that no one had written this book
so that was a really important book for
me and then the second book that was
really me in terms of my voice was was a
later book that I wrote called the queer
art of failure which is really a kind of
goofy irreverent book and it it it
managed to I managed to infuse it with a
voice that is quite specifically mine